[ __ ] getting old though [ __ ] cause the
moves wasn't as christmas it used to be
yo that nigga's like going through the
[Applause]
paces
[Applause]
and i'm wondering why he kept covering
his [ __ ] face
you know through the whole show then the
hand came down i was like put it back up
[ __ ]
[ __ ] that [ __ ] look like the female
monkey from planet earth
i don't know when i watched the movie i
swapping down it was michael [ __ ]
i'm like they don't want to tell nobody
that michael's doing this [ __ ] so they
changed the night
and that's michael jackson if that
[ __ ] bleach himself one more
time he's gonna be clear
send that [ __ ] to afghanistan
invisible [ __ ]
all they'll see is moonwalk steps in the
sand [ __ ]
be here and [ __ ]
[Applause]
no no no no no no
your bird is mine no but
muslim black i don't play but
you know what i'm saying that [ __ ] get
to heaven god ain't gonna recognize
the michael i made got a fro and a big
old [ __ ] no
what the [ __ ] is this pencil [ __ ] write
me a note
and they always complaining about how
papa joe whooped their ass
like he's the bad guy [ __ ] i wish i did
have a father like that [ __ ] to whoop
my ass in the fame [ __ ] he beat them
[ __ ] in the superstar
they need to run over there and kiss his
dick you know what i mean [ __ ] you got
a hundred million dollars [ __ ] go get
some therapy what the [ __ ] you complain
about
when i was 15 he beat me oh shut up
[ __ ] my mama beat me this far whoop my
ass when i get off so i can end up like
them [ __ ]
[Applause]
trip man whatever happened to pimps man
what if michael jackson was a pimp
should be him and tito be riding around
in the cadillac and [ __ ]
slow down tito so round tee don't damn
is that my hope that's sitting on the
curb
let me out come here girl
i said come here girl all my money how
much you got
i'm like i'm sorry all i got is a
hundred dollar bill girl you've been out
here all day and all you got 100
[Applause]
bills
i found my manager called me up and said
yo man michael jackson
man i was like so
you know cuz i [ __ ] mike up you know
mike
mike don't wait but a buck 05 you know i
bust that ass on my god
i was looking for my but my manager said
you know we don't know everything about
michael jackson he might be this bad
[ __ ] behind closed doors
he's a recluse you know behind closed
doors he might be completely different
and i'll be at the party and have
michael walk up to me one day and be
like this
can i talk to you for a minute
yeah uh what's your [ __ ]
problem man well how come you keep
[ __ ] with me then huh
what's all the [ __ ] jokes you
don't like my toenails what's your
[ __ ] problem
you know what i'm like a [ __ ]
jazz and i will brush your ass get the
[ __ ] out my [ __ ]
i'll moonwalk all up and down your ass
[ __ ] you mind your [ __ ]
business i hear some emotion i'ma put
this glove up your ass
i'll see you later
that's a dumb i could never i've been
trying for five months to do the move up
and i can't do this [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] it's the dumbest dance ever
because i can't do it that's why i
saying stupid but
how can you do the moonwalk and ask a
woman to dance it should be at the party
hey baby come on let's dance see you
later
through the moonwalk that's some stupid
[ __ ] michael can do that [ __ ] though
michael's so famous
michael went on television and
everything he says the public believes
went on television and said
i don't have sex because of my religious
beliefs and the public believed it
i know brothers was like get the [ __ ]
out of here
and white people are going that
michael's a special kind of guy
he's special i mean he's good clean and
wholesome
y'all believe you know how i knew y'all
believed it y'all didn't get mad when
you took brook shields to grammys
nobody white said [ __ ] and brook shields
is the whitest woman in america
that's miss america every year brook
[ __ ] who you see with the crown
brook you look a white woman in
dictionary a picture of brook like this
she's white and this [ __ ] took her to
grammys nobody said [ __ ]
if i took brook shields and grammys
y'all lose your mind
cause y'all know brook would get [ __ ]
that night
michael jackson lost his mind
what the hell is wrong with michael
another kid
another cat i thought it was groundhog's
day when i heard that [ __ ]
another kick getting the [ __ ] out of
here
yo that's how much we love michael we
love michael so much
we let the first kid slide
another kid i'm [ __ ] done i'm talking
michael
i thought i was a fan my whole life i am
[ __ ]
done i'm handed him my glove okay
i saw michael on 60 minutes
ed bradley tried his best to make
michael look like a mammal
somebody that drank water and breathed
air right
he gave michael the easiest questions in
the world the easiest ged
questions in the world and michael could
not
pass the test it's like oh michael
do you think it's proper for a 45 year
old man
to sleep in a bed with thirteen-year-old
boys
[Applause]
yes
okay okay uh let me rephrase that
oh michael would you let your
children sleep in the bed of a 45 year
old man
that's been accused of child molestation
yes
ed bradley looked at michael jackson
like he wanted to say
[ __ ] you crazy
like he wanted to take the 60 minutes
clock and push the [ __ ] forward
to get the [ __ ] off my show
i thought you said it was 60 minutes
it's 10 minutes get out of here
y'all nutty [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you
i'm done with michael man you see
michael go to court
i'm about to come to court 20 minutes
later
what kind of black man gonna come to
cult
20 minutes late this ain't barbershop
too this
is caught [ __ ] [ __ ] and he don't
even wear a real
suit to cook coming in there looking
like captain crunch
so who's your lawyer frankenberry
better take your black ass to banana
republic and get you a decent suit
the [ __ ] is wrong with that boy i'm done
with [ __ ] mike
that's like another dead white girl
showing up at oj's house
and oj going i know what you're thinking
michael jackson going to jail it's going
to be a sad
sight when michael jackson go to jail oh
we going to shut the table michael
jackson go to jail
and it ain't even gonna be sad today
he'll go in it's gonna be sad like a
month
later when that perm grows out of his
[Applause]
hair
the shit's all nappy and gray
with his makeup so [ __ ] up so he don't
got the crayola people to fix his face
no more
that's a [ __ ] sad ass sight
remember when he's young everybody just
have those arguments about who's better
michael jackson or prince prince won
and that's why i don't trip off being a
celebrity i don't like it
i don't trust it just one minute they
all love you and the next thing you know
you're in front of that courthouse
dancing on top of a car just trying to
figure out what the [ __ ] happened to you
[Applause]
here's what i'm waiting for because the
timing of this michael jackson [ __ ] is
what makes me doubt it every time
this war is going out of control or the
economy gets bad or something is wrong
with the world at large
it's always these moments in history
that
michael jackson will coincidentally jerk
awful kid this is getting
ridiculous like are you planning this
[ __ ] do you have meetings
michael thank you for coming as you know
michael the war has not been going as
well as we expected there's been a lot
of hiccups and the public is
asking us a lot of questions of course
and well michael there's no nice way to
say this and
all i know how to do is be direct so let
me just be direct
we're gonna need you to jerk off another
child mike i'm sorry
i am sorry
but it would really help out
or maybe he didn't who knows who knows
that's the thing that's what i wanted to
say who knows who the [ __ ] knows
mike god and this little boy know that's
that's about it
that's about it the only reason that i
can even
talk about this [ __ ] is because
everybody is
speculating they all think he did it and
i don't think he did it i'm alone in
this i don't think he did it
i'm not gonna say i don't think he did
it that's too strong
[Music]
let me just say i am reserving judgment
until all the facts come out but so far
from what i heard i mean the kid said he
was dying of cancer
he was in make-a-wish foundation he
claims he had two weeks to live
and it was his dying wish
to meet michael jackson come on man give
me a [ __ ] break
this kid is 10 years old he don't
remember thriller the [ __ ] you want to
meet michael jackson for honestly
i remember thrilling and i just like
kind of want to meet this [ __ ] like
i wouldn't break an appointment i mean
i'll put it that way i'd have to already
be free
that's ridiculous like if i'm dying in
two weeks and go oh mama oh
get me in the room with chubby chuckle i
wouldn't want to meet that [ __ ]
that
my leg is two weeks why not usher
somebody like this
so then the kid claims he goes to
michael's house this is where it all
gets crazy i don't
like you know he does everything you'd
expect at michael's house they uh
climbed trees and rode roller coasters
and ferris wheels the chef made cookies
pies and cakes
that was petting the monkey and giraffes
sing songs
kid [ __ ] and in the middle of all this
childlike activity
for some reason mike pulled out some
wine and some pills
[Applause]
and sucked this kid's dick folks it
hurts me to safety
and the kid had the nerve to call that
abuse [ __ ] that
is a good host god damn what else do you
want
what else do you want
i'm lucky to get a glass of grape drink
in my friend's house
let alone a roller coaster riding my
dick sucked
mike must be confused like i brought you
in my house i fed you
i sucked your dick and this is how you
repay me [ __ ]
this was your wish not man
thought you were dying in two weeks what
happened to that [ __ ]
i've been in court for a year and a half
you get strong every time i see you
when that this is [ __ ] up i shouldn't
even say the [ __ ]
wouldn't be some ironic [ __ ] if they
found out through this case that the
cure for cancer
was michael jackson sucking your dick
somehow
[Applause]
like if mike had powers like green mile
and all the kids like please mike's i
got this
never again you didn't appreciate it
can we at least study your saliva
please viking
it just doesn't stop though it just
doesn't stop
and the only reason i can talk about
mike is because he's a freak
he's a freak that's why people let you
talk about
because if i brought up catholic priests
[ __ ] kids it'll get quiet as [ __ ]
but but when michael jackson does it
it's okay
because he's a freak his face is all cut
up but just remember when you look at
that
thing that he calls his face that he did
that for you somehow
somehow he thought you might maybe it'll
help maybe people will like me more
if i turn myself into a white ghoulish
like creature i don't know what the [ __ ]
it is
but he did it for you and i appreciate
the gesture michael jackson if you're
watching this
i appreciate that gesture and i want you
to know [ __ ] everybody
dave chappelle understands cause you
want to know something
i'm getting some work done surprise yes
nothing major you would never know if i
didn't tell you but it's some [ __ ] i'm
insecure about
that i want to work on if you must know
i'm getting botox done on my bowls to
get these wrinkles out finally
have these just smooth as eggs
no i can't wait